this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history
on this week's episode he's going to be
breaking down the eclectic range of
weapons
in resident evil village what makes no
sense at all
is this upgrade system the red dot sight
on there the menu informs me
customizable part for increased power
and rate of fire
two things that a site definitely can't
do for you is increase the power of your
shots
or the speed of them make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this
including jonathan's thoughts on the
weapons of resident evil 4 and 7.
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you want to see jonathan
break down
let us know in the comment section below
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video
right over to jonathan
so i gather that's the that's your
starting pistol which
is interesting i believe it's the cz2075
it's czed's relatively modern concealed
carry sized pistol which i suppose makes
sense as a starting weapon
the main thing of interest isn't so much
the weapon as
the reload it's a retention reload he's
keeping the magazine he takes out and
swapping to a fresh one
they've chosen a realistic animation for
someone who's had some tactical training
that is a reload you would do
to preserve the maximum amount of
ammunition if you've got
supernatural creatures coming at you
health health or leather you're not
going to
retain the magazine gracefully you're
gonna get it out of the gun
get another mag in keep shooting until
there's nothing about to kill you
then pick up the magazines that you've
discarded whether or not they have
rounds in them
it's just a word on ammunition um this
being
set where it is and the sort of
creatures that you're fighting i'm a bit
disappointed that i've not seen
anything in the way of silver bullets
which as everyone knows
are for shooting werewolves silver
bullets were attempted against the beast
of jevaldan
in in france which is not i don't think
was ever thought to be a werewolf it was
just like a giant beast
so the folklore fiction nut in me is a
bit disappointed that we don't have
any silver bullets in this game
comfortable fully automatic
all right insta pause on that one right
so we've got m1911 so we've actually got
a correct designation for the
colt 1911 derived pistol this time which
in
resident evil 7 we didn't this is a
straight up cult 1911
government model pistol and they called
it a 1911
but then the description says a
comfortable fully automatic handgun i
think that's a contradiction in terms i
don't think any fully automatic handgun
is uh
comfortable i don't know if we're
looking at an early build or something
but that description
definitely said the m1911 was fully
automatic and i was about to complain
about how
fully automatic 1911's do exist but then
but not
factory-made they're all converted built
for gangsters
that sort of thing but then as depicted
in that clip
bear in mind i haven't played this game
yet it is semi-automatic so i'm not sure
what i'm missing there
this is an odd implementation of the
scorpion machine pistol submachine gun
whatever you want to call it machine
pistol
sub machine gun at least by one
definition the one in the game that i
was shown is semi-automatic only
as is this one this is a commercially
available four civilians
pistol the really striking thing about
that weapon
was the stock because the stock on that
was like no scorpion stock that
i've ever seen and as far as i know does
not exist
it's a sort of pseudo-dragon of inspired
wood and steel fixed buttstock now the
whole point of the scorpion
is that it is compact so it's kind of
strange
to not see the scorpion used as you know
a sort of
one-handed blaze away machine pistol and
instead to see it used as a sort of
pistol caliber carbine
i did not expect to see one of these in
a resident evil game although i don't
know why not thinking about it
it's uh not a franchise known for its
slavish adherence to realism
not that the gyro jet isn't realistic
the gyro jet is real
it did slash does exist we also have
a fired round uh you may or may not be
able to see that it has
little rocket vents in the base because
these are miniature rockets
this is basically a real-life warhammer
40k
volta pistol because it's a rocket
pistol it's got a really weird loading
system as well so as
you see in the game there's no magazine
in the grip well there is but it's not
reloadable to actually to open it up i'm
not sure i saw this in the animation but
you actually have to
press this catch on the right side and
then open up the
rear of the pistol it's not a slide
because it doesn't reciprocate
and then the hammer strikes the nose of
the cartridge
knocks it backwards onto this striker
which hits the primer in the base
much like a conventional cartridge and
then the rocket exhaust starts
jetting out of those holes in the base
of the round and it
slowly makes its way out the barrel
and that's reflected in the firing
animation where there's a
perceptible delay between firing it and
the projectile hitting the target
and a sort of explosive projectile
effect when it hits something in real
life that's not the case
i don't think they made any payload
bearing ammunition for this
so it's just a really slow not very good
bullet
the weapon is yet again the winchester
870
and we don't have to guess because the
in-game name is w870 which is probably
just as well because this version is
so disguised with bits that um
it might have tripped me up frankly at
first over the top
clamped onto the what i believe was
originally a mount for a side saddle
shotgun shell holder is a like a shroud
that gives you a top picatinny rail and
a heat shield out the front and it
totally
changes the outline of the gun so the
870s all over the world
so very plausible to come across it and
increasingly people do like to
play dress-up with their guns so you
might find one
with some bits and bobs on it or of
course there's an in-game armorer again
for this game
so it's possible that he's dressed it up
or you're you know you're customizing it
clearly as you go along
this is quite a curious bit of legally
different naming here we've got syg12
psyc12 you stumble over your words it's
almost like saiga 12 which is what this
actually is of sega
it's a 12 gauge semi-automatic variant
of the kalashnikov system quite popular
around the world
increasingly popular actually and
certainly in eastern europe so
this actually in some ways makes us more
sense than some other appearances of the
saiga
what makes no sense at all is this
upgrade system
and this is the first time that this has
become really apparent to me
in the the red dot sight on there the
menu informs me
customizable part for increased power
and rate of fire
two things that a site definitely can't
do for you is increase the power of your
shots
or the speed of them it doesn't look to
me as though the site is even on
i think you'd see some residual glow
from the reticle on the glass
in that low light condition so it's like
a
site that gives you increased power and
rate of fire that
doesn't function as a site
[Music]
i think of the the guns i've seen from
this game
this um what they're calling m1851
wolf spain is easily my favorite it fits
the setting
so well and it's a really nice example
of an in-game decorated gun embellished
guns in video games are often
really over the top and they don't look
like a real engraved decorated
damascene firearm but this is this is
much more like it and maybe it's just my
taste but the
the black and gold it's just a it's a
it's still over the top don't get me
wrong but it's
it fits quite nicely although i don't
really understand the m1851 designation
because looking at it in the character's
hand
and in the proportions of it it really
looks much more like
one of these dragoon the colt dragoon
which predates
the 1851 navy which is what the
designation of this is alluding to
it is really a mashup of different cults
if i had to lay money i'd say this is
meant to be
front half dragoon slash navy but
octagonal barrel
back half 1872. yeah i quite quite like
it i'm not complaining per se
nice to see a specific model represented
but something that's just
a cult without being a cult and it's
meant to be like a one-off magical
weapon i think it works really well
so the old um wildy magnum which uh
if i remember rightly in resident evil 7
had a hint of the auto mag 3 about it
but um primarily the wildly makes a
comeback here i assume it's a
it's the standard or one of the standard
magnums not an unlockable
but that one is doing some serious
damage there so
that's got to be fully upgraded or
whatever i like the the dirty harry
style exaggerated
recoil animation although it's
interesting how if you want to fire
faster
he brings it down quicker not completely
implausible
some people prefer to sort of ride the
recoil and then let it settle back down
into the sights
so if you're trying to engage targets
more quickly you would just muscle it
back down
yeah it was it was an interesting choice
for resident evil 7 and it's
an interesting choice here
quite an eclectic selection of firearms
so far and the sniper rifles
no exception this is the french fr
f2 which is still i believe the current
french military sniper rifle in 762 nato
one of those weapons in the game that is
really quite close to
the real life gun and this is in fact
the correct scope
reticle for the fr f2 this you can find
it online which is
probably what the developers did and so
they have actually used
the correct scope reticle for this rifle
which um
it's not a first because it has been
done before but that's normally the
preserve of
more sort of milsim type or tactical
shooters it's
relatively rare to get a faithfully
represented
scope for you
uh another legally different name wcx
which is a
a mirrored version of the mcx from sig
sauer without having the real thing to
compare to hand
it looks like there are a few too many
lumps and bumps on it so it might be
deliberately a bit different or maybe
it's just the finish that's throwing me
off the basic configuration is correct
and it's a become a very popular
tactical 556 rifle so yeah it fits the
setting
roll wise it sort of takes the place of
the bison from um
resident evil 7 and both of them seem to
operate a bit more like
a generic video game machine gun to me
it might be being a bit unfair
rate of fire seems a little slow for
something like the mcx
yeah it's something a bit different and
it's it's fascinating
over time to see trends as to what's a
cool tactical rifle
change and for a long time it was ar-15s
all day long and
things like sigs are now getting a look
in and gains just like they are in the
real world
we've got another kalashnikov derivative
or rather variants
this is some sort of short barrelled
ak generically known as a krinkov
although that's a legitimate term for
the akr-74u
or a draco it's like a based on a
available parts kit that comes in and is
built up as a short barreled
rifle or a pistol we've got accessories
on there i don't know to what extent
those are customizable or whether they
come
like that in this case but um what what
intrigued slash amused me were the
rubber bands that are on the gun so
we've got one around the
pressure switch on the foregrip which
looks like it might be there to keep the
light on
and then there's another one
inexplicably wrapped around the buffer
tube bit or there's not a buffer tube in
the gun on the buttstock maybe that's a
spare i don't know
always handy to have elastic bands
around i suppose
there's an m79 in the game this one is
highly decorated and again i think
they've done
quite a nice job with the decorated
firearms of making them look like
something that
might exist in reality even though it
wouldn't exist in reality because no one
in the right minds would do that to an
m79
but in terms of the execution the
modeling and the texturing
a nice job a weird nerdy quirk that you
watch these videos for
when it breaks open the gun and pulls
out the empty
case the rifling looks really funky and
goes all the way
to the back of the barrel which means
you'd have to have grooves cut in the
cartridge case
and i don't know why you would do that
so firearms have chambers
and the chambers are not rifled they are
sometimes fluted
so that propellant gases can be used to
help extract the case but that's not
what we're seeing here what we're seeing
here is someone who's not understood how
rifling works unfortunately
yeah but a bit of an odd one but overall
the the modelling of that weapon was
was good
what an interesting contraption this is
basically the ride on lawn mower from
hell
and you've got a trusty chainsaw which i
think is
to affect some sort of guard with or to
try to you've got a
an m250 caliber 50 browning machine gun
on the right hand side
which reloads itself magically and then
what it calls the cannon
is i can't quite see where that sits
relative to you as the driver but there
is actually like a what looks to be a
an spg9 or similar recoilless weapon
mounted on this thing so again that is
magically reloaded
on its own in reality you'd need at
least two guys
hanging off the back of this trying not
to get taken out by the back blast of
the recoilless
round but it's very very inventive now
you can actually see at one point
fitted to the rear of the m2 machine gun
is actually a solenoid style firing
mechanism so they've bothered to
think about how you're actually firing
that with a remote trigger
essentially so an electrical signal is
sent to a switch
and it's the switch which fires the
actual gun an interesting bit of
attention to detail in an otherwise
completely insane
agglomeration of weapons
here at the royal armouries we are happy
to be open once again
at leeds as well as our fort nelson site
do come and pay us a visit if you're
able
if you've not and you'd like to support
us another way there are links in the
description for that
we've also got our own series of short
videos on
objects from the collection that might
interest you over on the royal armouries
channel
otherwise we'll see you again next time
thanks for watching
[Music]
you